الاحتلال واليه الاحتلال تمكنا من الوصول
لهذه المستشفى بعد تراجع القوات من هذه
المنطقه لنشاهد حجم هذه الجريمه الذي
ارتكبها الاحتلال داخل هذه المستشفى بحق
النازحين وبحق الطواقم الطبيه وبحق
المستشفى الوحيد الذي كان يعمل هنا في
شمال قطاع غزه قامت جرافات
الاحتلال بتجريف المستشفى هنا بالكامل كما
نشاهد حجم هذا الدمار الكبير لكن الجريمه
الا اكبر هو قيام
الجرافات بتجريف النازحين داخل هذه
المستشفى ممن كانوا نازحين داخل ساحه هذه
المستشفى قامت
الجرافات بتجريف وكانهم تراب كما نشاهد
هنا جثمان احد المصابين قامت جرافات
الاحتلال بالتجريف
عليه وقتله في هذا المكان في بنت عايشه
باقي في
المستشفى دكتور زي ما انت شايف مستشفى
الوحيد اللي كان شغال في شمال غزه طبعا تم
تحييده عن الخدمه هذا شهيد تم الدوس عليه
بالجرافه ودفنه بالطريقه هذه انا عمال لسه
من شويه حاولت ابين وجهه وذا انعرف الشهيد
من دار مرسي تمام عوده عوده مرسي كويس هذ
هذا مبنى الصيدليه ما تبقى من الصيدليه ما
تبقى من الصيدليه
الصيدليه الوحيده في شمال غزه اللي كانت
تقدم ما تستطيع تقديمه للجاره للاسف
الشديد هذا ما تبقى منها هذا ما تبقى من
صيدليه تخدم ما يقارب النصف مليون مواطن
مبنى
الاداره مش عارف انا كيف السيارات طلعت
بالطريقه هذ هذا ارهاب مش طبيعي هذا ارهاب
مش طبيعي هذا مبنى الاداره السياره تطلع
بالطريقه هذه لقدام طبعا الصيدليه زي ما
انت شايف
شهداء اللي كانوا موجودين لسه ه موجودين
في شهداء حيتم حيتم الحديث عنهم هول لسه
سابق لقدام شوي هنا في موجودين شهدا تحت
تحت الانقاد هنا تم الدوس عليهم بجات
احياء
تمام مش معروف لحتى اللحظه هذه مش معروف
طبعا للاسف الشديد هذا هذا ما يغترف
الاحتلال هذا ما يغرف الاحتلال هذ
ترولي هذ ترولي بتقدم بتقدم
للجرحى ما تستطيع تقديمه
[موسيقى]
طبعا هذه ساحه المستشفى الرئيسيه المستشفى
الرئيسيه يتم يتم العبد فيها بالطريقه هذه
هذه ساحه مستشفى الوحيد الذي يخدم شمال
غزه بعد تحييد المستشفى الاندونيسي ريف
السيارات على الشهداء وبعض الشهداء
موجودين لحد اللحظه هذه هذه سياره لد
اللحظه
تمام زي ما انت شايف تم التجريف تم تجريف
م احياء تم تجريف المواطنين احياء
النازحين والمرضى والمرضى
والنازحين
بالطريقه الاجراميه اللي انتم شايفينها
تفضل وين المجتمع الدولي من هذه من هذه
المناظر وين المجتمع الدولي من هذا من هذه
الاشلاء وين المجتمع الدولي وين الامم
المتحده وين العالم اللي مش قادر يحقق
عداله عداله للشعب الفلسطيني هذا هذا ما
تبقى
لدينا طبعا حتلاقي بعض بعض كثير من
الشهداء لسه احنا مش عارفين يعني هذه هذه
بعض بعض الاشلاء الموجوده للاسف اللي
الشباب يساعدونا تم تجريف تم تجريف تم
تجريف و احياء تم
تجري يلا نطلع نكمل مع
هذه المجزره لسه في شهداء طبعا ه كل
المنطقه هذه كلها كانت شهداء زي ما انت
شايف هي هي بعض الجثث هذه جريمه جريمه يجب
من اترف هذه الجريمه ومن
امر جيش الاحتلال بفعل هذه الجريمه يجب ان
يحاكم المحاكمه الدوليه ويجب ان يمنع من
دخول دول العالم العالم الظالم للاسف
الشديد العالم الذي لم يستطيع تحقيق
العداله ولا وقف اطلاق النار حتى للشعب
فلسطيني هذا مكان النازحين الذين نزحوا
خوفا من الموت جاء الاحتلال الى داخل
المستشفى وقتلهم بدم بارد وتم تجريف بنفس
الطريقه مكان النازحين الاف النازحين كان
موجودين فيها وتم تجريف برضه احياء الاف
النازحين اللي اجوا وال تجوا للمستشفى
خوفا من بطش الاحتلال وخوفا من الموت جاء
الاحتلال الى هنا ليقتلهم بدم بارد ويدوس
عليهم بالجرافات ويدوس عليهم بالدبابات
ويدفنهم وهم احياء ت دفن من النازحين
الذين هربوا خوفا من الموت في هذه المنطقه
احياء يجب ان يقدم كل من شارك في هذه
الجريمه الى المحاكم الدوليه يجب يجب يجب
يلا يلا
يلا تع يجب ان يقدموا الى المحاكمه جميعهم
جميعهم يقدم للمحاكمه النازحين الذين
كانوا في هذا المكان النازحين الذين هربوا
من الموت النازحين الذين لجوا الى هنا تم
تجريف محياء بالطريقه هذه هذه جثه تم هذا
هذا مصاب هذا مصاب تم اصابته هنا في في
داخل المستشفى وتم تجريف اين المجتمع
الدولي واين هيئه الامم المتحده من منهذه
هذه الجرائم التي ترتكب بحق الشعب
الفلسطيني هذا مصاب هذا مصاب تمام وتم دوس
عليه بالجرافه طبعا في المكان هنا في كمان
جثه شوف
[موسيقى]
جرائم الاحتلال امام امام العالم امام
العالم امام امام من هذا هذا منظر يرضي
المجتمع الدولي هذا هذه جثه تحللت هذه
الجثث تحللت بعد ان تم الدوس عليها
بالجرافات والدبابات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
هذه جثه ايضا لامراه نشاهد هنا احد
الاطفال
الذين بقوا داخل هذه المستشفى الاحتلال
ارتكب جريمه بحق هؤلاء
الاطفال هذول وهدول الاصابات لهم ع ايام
في المستشفى وبمجرد ما انه انسحبوا اليهود
جيت اخذهم على وجه السرعه وزي ما انت شايف
هؤلاء حالات كلها حرق كامل بدون اي سبب
بدون اكل بدون شرب بدون عنايه عصبات كثيره
جوا ه كله زائد زائده انه في كمان اصابات
انا مش قادر احملها من الي عساف من مجزره
الي عساف بدون اي ذنب وبعد ما اجيت على
المستشفى لقيت دمار هائل لا يمكن
بوصفه والعيانين مرميين في كل قرنه
والفراش مرمى والادوات الصحيه مزعه ولا في
اي شيء صالح للحياه الحالات الانسانيه حرب
بكل معالم
الانسانيه حرب ما مرت قبل ه ه طفل ثلاث
سنين محروق من رجلين لاخ لراسه كله حروق
والبنت حروق وما خفي كان اعظم جوا حاجات
بتخوف جوا لا يمكن وصفها لا يمكن وصف
الجرام اللي جوا عش ايام لا اكل لا شرب
دمار كامل جوا على العيانين وهي ابن اخوي
يا شادي عساف مشلول ولقيته تحت الكراسي
مرمي على على ظهره كل الاواعي والاكل
والخشب فوقيه وحالات عديده حدث ولا حرج
والله بقدر اف كتب عن الليف صار في كمال
عدوان كتب مجلدات عن الصوره المهينه في
كمال
[موسيقى]
عدوان
بابا صرفوا كمال عدوان كل هيتها القصف
علينا من كل الجهات بهدلونا وحاصروه
بهدلونا وحاصروها وحرقوا الاجسام كل هيتها
والصيدليه ما في دواء للمرضى بعدين هنا
صارت مجزره كبيره عننا ه طلعوا الجرحه في
البرد وال مرقون جوا الجثث على الارض
مرميه لها اس لها اسبوع لها اسبوع الجثث
الجثس لها اسبوع مرميه ما خلوش حدا يروح
يدفنهم محصر من جميع الجهات وطلعوا جث
الجرافات يعني كنا قاعدين على اعصابنا جرف
الارض يطلعوا الجثث من الارض بنعرف ايش
دهسوا عليهم اخذوهم ما بنعرف وين ودوهم
ربطوا الشباب بالجنازير في ايديهم واخذوهم
سحوه خلوهم بالكلاس
شيذ مع
السجني طلعوهم في البرد والسقعه وهذا اللي
عننا وحسبنا الله ونعم الوكيل حنا بناشد
المسلمين
والعرب هسينا كلهم عندهم طيارات وعندهم
دبابات وعندهم كل شي وفوا على اسرائيل تفه
غرقوها ليش هم الرؤساء بعملوا فينا هيك
احنا مش بنقدمين كل واحد جا دوره مدرسه
خليفه وجاب هنا 11 يوم واحين هنا في الارض
والله ولا اكل ولا شرب اي حاجه وعملوا
اخذوا زلينا كلهم ولحو بالبكسرات وهنو عند
دورنا اخذوهم عند البراوي بعد البراوي
ورموهم عند وقالوا لهم اتجهوا على جنوب هم
مش الحين وضربوهم اسوا معامله حسبي الله
ونعم الوكيل
بس اب محمد عبد
الله لفله من هين لف لله من الغار
[موسيقى]
لفل ع ايام هدول 10م جهنم حصار المستشفى
ففي كان بعض من الشهداء هنا اللي نزفوا
واستشهدوا فما حدا دفنهم
ف استشهدوا دفنوا في التراب نفسه في
المستشفى موجودين
اي بدي احكي لك وضع ماساوي ايش بدي
احكي وضع ماساوي في جوره قبل 30 متر تحت
الارض ايش حطوا فيها ايش دفنوا فيها الله
اعلم ورجعوا طمها الصبح وغير الاهانات
اللي احنا تعرضنا لها في التحقيق معهم
واليهود اخذوا منهم كمان نازحين غير
الاهانات والضرب اللي كانت يتعرضو لها من
الاحتلال الحمد لله زي ما انت شايف قدامك
نص الكادر الطبي تبعنا راح والنص الثاني
ما رجعش مش عارفين وينه فمنهم من الكادر
الطبي اخذوا نائب نائب مدير التمريض عماد
حمدونه هذا اللي احنا بنعرفه لحتى الان
الباقي ما بنعرف عنهم اي شيء انا جاي ادور
على ابني مصاب ومش ملاقيه واليهود هدين
المستشفى على على الجرحه وع المرضى حتى
الدكاتره ما سالمين منهم ولا دكتور ولا
حدا
الشهدا كل تراب يا عم اطلع اطلع الدكاتره
الدكاتره اللي بقوا هنا ما فيش دكاتره
قاتلين مهدين المباني عليهم وين وين
الاتحاد اوروبا وين وين امريكا اللي هي
اللي بتكل فينا امريكا قاعده حسب الله
ونعم الوكيل عليهم وين الرص العرب ابن
ابني كان مصاب هنا و ماشي صار قصف وقع لي
حجر حطيته هون عدود شردنا لقيناهم هدين
المبنى مقلين الدكاتره مش مخليين حاجه اي
اي ابني ه مش عارف اطوله مش عارف اطول
ابني مشان الله وين الدول العربيه وين هي
العش تبعه نفسي اي ها نفسي جاي اعطيه نفسي
ابني عيان مش ملاقيه تحت التراب دفنينه
حتى حتى اللي بغسل الموته دفنينه ه معهم
حتى اللي بغسل الموته دفنينه الدكاتره
دفنينه مش مخلين حنا ولا مبنى ولا حاجه
اقول له غزه غزه لا تصلح سكن هلقيت غزه ما
بتصلح لسكن خلص احنا انتهينا كل انسان كان
عنده حلم راح فش اللي كان بده يجوز ابنه
اللي كان بده يعلم ابنه كله تدمر كله خلص
ماظل ما ضلش ان الله الا الله ما خلوا
حاجه في المستشفى اطلع اطلع علي الضمان
منلاقي اللي بلاقيه وما نلاقيه حسبنا الله
ونعم الوكيل وين نروح من مدرسه مدرسه من
مستشفى مستشفى مرمطونا هدوا ديارنا هدوا
دورنا وين نروح يعني احنا من ناجه الامم
العربيه والاجانب يحلونا وقف اطاط نار
نهائيا والله تعبنا كل الضور تدمرت حسبي
الله ونعم الوكيل اكثر من هيك واححد ما
يحكي اخذونا اليهود فتشونا ربطونا وبهدلو
بهدل حسبنا الله ونعم الوكيل خلونا
عريانين
ودونا اللي انت شايفه اللبس بهدلونا اللبس
المخمج هذا الرمه حسبنا الله ونعم الوكيل
وين نروح يعني نزحنا هان كموى يعني نا
فاجت اليهود قتلت ناس ناس اندفنت ه تحتك
واطفالنا مات من الخوف في جرحى كان وضعهم
بامكانهم يعيشوا بس
عشان معدات انهم يتعالجوا فماتوا وراحوا
فيها حسبي الله ون السبب احنا بدنا حل
جدري عن جد تعبنا ماضل فينا ح قرايب ايش
ضايل كل شي را حتى المستشفيات خربهم حسبي
الله ونعم الوكيل حتى خيم خيم وين بدنا
نروح احنا ورودنا حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل
واحد كان السبب كما
شاهدتم جريمه ارتكبها الاحتلال بحق مستشفى
كمال عدوان وبحق الجرحى والمرضى في داخل
هذا المستشفى انس الشريف لصالح قناه
الجزيره شمال
غزه